hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker no
I didn't take a break in between last
one but I didn't because you know I'm in
a weird happy place now and to shabby
I gotta admit it's not that not the
worst place I've ever been you know I
feel I feel I feel okay now you know I
feel like you know what I do is and I
you know I shouldn't let things get and
that's probably like a problem was I
just don't let things see me I'll be
okay as long as you know I don't ignore
the things that are very obviously going
against what I very obviously go against
what I want them to do because you know
in my brain I know what to do
I I do I definitely know what to do and
it's not a problem what to do like it's
it's you know it's Brian's stupid
controller that doesn't want to do but I
wanted to do so you know if things just
did what I asked them to do then I'd
probably be a lot better about things
you know but as it as it stands you know
I did that there I probably did like the
impossible the developer probably didn't
even know that someone could you know do
me that what I did there with the you
know without dive-bombing he probably
was like there's obviously not enough
time to do that that way so someone
would you know they'd have to do it the
way I have it in my mind right that's
probably what he thought Oh silly silly
man didn't know about me and me playing
game
not a lot of people do not a lot of
people do know about me playing the game
except for you guys out there
as I've said you're literally all I have
I don't have a Danny I don't have I got
a me and some of you are probably like
well mark if you just you know stop
screaming so much you'd be able to do
that and you know you got you got a you
got a point there you got a point
but sometimes oh your hopes and dreams
are dead now you know something like
that happens and it's uh you know it's
not a problem really I wouldn't feel too
bad about it but you know it just is
what it is so welcome back to super
mario maker
i am okay was about as real as a
markiplier playthrough gets this is this
is the realest real that you'll ever see
and it's good good it's good stuff
aren't you guys glad that i started up
mario maker again so anyway I kind of
ordered these in like rank of not at a
6.4 - I'm just bad that's all there is
to it but anyway
so now we're gonna continue playing this
game I don't have a Danny I don't have
an Aaron all I got is me myself and you
guys so together we're gonna play a good
old-fashioned game here and have lots of
fun
I detect lots of douchey Ross like traps
in this level and I don't much
appreciate but that being said well I
didn't do that oh no my thing ran out of
batteries oh great okay I'm back
so this okay there we are
so these levels are ranked in terms of
not quite about difficulty but they're
pretty close so we're just gonna have a
fun little time anyway did I ever tell
you guys about the time that I did I
ever tell you guys about the time that I
broke my arm because that was an
interesting experience I will admit I
was actually I was about I forget I was
12 or something maybe 13 or 14 so I was
visiting my mom son of you some of you
may have known that my parents divorced
when I was very young it's fine like
it's not a big deal to me like it's not
the worst thing in the world I choked up
about it everyday it's cool I can talk
about but uh so there was joint custody
between my dad and my mom so I went to
visit my mom and she had to go do
something I forget exactly what it was
I'm not entirely sure she ever told me
and probably doesn't matter what it was
but she had to drop us off somewhere so
she thought the best place to hold us
for a few hours was a park in the middle
of inner Cincinnati
like a very probably not the best place
for children kind of place if you know
what I'm talking about so we are there
and it's totally fun we're plenty of
games there's no one else at the park
were playing that the floor is lava on
the play sets me and my brother my
brother's there by the way and you know
we're playing lots of fun games and
whatever we're having a great time so we
do our thing for however long it takes
to get our things done and while we're
waiting for our mom two other kids from
the neighborhood or whatever
neighborhood we were in I forget exactly
where this was in particular but two
other kids come along and then we decide
to play on the jungle gym so or the
monkey box so playing on the monkey bars
and we're having a contest to see how
far out the monkey bars we can jump and
whoever jumps the farthest obviously is
the winner so with it being said we have
we take turns just jumping out as far as
we can and then it gets to the point
where we're practically jumping to the
opposite end of the monkey bars and
that's a bit problematic because my turn
came up and I had to prove myself to
everybody else there that I was the best
and I was the best or I was going to be
the best but I accidentally went so far
that I fell and shattered my arm in both
of them so when I stood up my arm was
like a it was like this weird staircase
stepping like right there and it didn't
hurt like the weird thing was that it
did not hurt at all it actually is
completely painless which was
exceptionally bizarre
wait that doesn't wait that's that how
well no no no huh no oh no good oh no oh
no oh oh no it'll be fine okay it'll be
fine huh I thought everything was going
horribly Africa Oh No
everything is bad god damn it
oh my arm was broken at this point and
it didn't hurt it didn't hurt at all
which was very bizarre right up until
the point where I decided to set it
myself because it was it didn't hurt and
my arm was a staircase and obviously
that's not right so in my mind I was
like I need to fix this so I grabbed it
by it's broken part and just squeeze
really tightly until both bones is kind
of locked back in place then the pain
started it hurt really bad after that
point which was a life lesson to learn
don't do that
it's stupid to try to set your own bone
even though the doctor when he saw my
broken bone said I had it almost
correctly you know he went up to me and
it was like oh you know you almost did a
great job here you almost had it
perfectly and then he grabbed my arm and
reset the bone snapping it in plane and
causing an immense amount of pain so
that was the time that I broke my arm
and I bring that up because I was in
pain just now so that was the other time
that I was in immense pain and not
having fun whereas now I'm having fun
this is a good level because things do
what I tell them to do and even though
there's this slight air of beautiness
it's alright ok alright so this may have
been the strangest Mario maker episode
you guys have ever experienced
but we learned that no matter how angry
markiplier gets everything's gonna be ok
am i right ladies and gentlemen I think
I'm right
so now that I've officially calmed back
down no oh God
ok I'm back and I'm in full form I swear
I am ok I'm better now god dammit didn't
mean to bring you out of your cage but
what I need to do is I need to take care
of that guy scoop up these [ __ ] take
these guys out and take these guys out
and then have a grand old time over here
with this thing doing if I didn't manage
to get that behind those blocks I would
not bad a good time ok alright I was
about to say is this it oh hang on a
second oh god oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no come on
oh can I just reset it can it be reset
please tell me it can be reset oh God
well what am I supposed to do oh why is
Hell befallen me oh I know how
do this properly because I'm gonna just
go over here find the gap and Islam just
met and I need to well I need to not do
all of them I think what I should do is
I should come over there and wait for
okay oh god I don't like this oh I don't
like that holy damn I did not I did not
know that I was gonna need that I'm glad
that I got that Oh God it'll come to me
and that's when I'll press the P I'll
press that P I'm gonna do this it's not
gonna stop me
what the hell over here
jump up here up here buddies where are
you going I have no idea what you're
doing
oh come on oh [ __ ]
oh no no no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it this level stupid I don't like
it I'm not having fun
nah I'm not having fun
Matt put some videos of me having fun
right here here's me having fun show up
there it is yes that's what I say about
that it's a bunch of bull it's stupid
anyone who approaches that yeah yeah
it's heck okay
so anyway that's all I have to say about
this episode thank you everybody so much
for watching and prepare for maybe more
Mario maker if you guys want more Mario
maker let me know down in the comments
below I will I do read comments by the
way I really do so I do hear what you
guys say almost all the time so thank
you everybody so much you want more
and as always